ونتابع التطورات عن قرب مع مراسلنا من
مخيم جباليه انس الشريف انس صف لنا ما
خلفه هذا القصف على مستوى الدمار وعن اخر
حصيله ايضا ان استقرت على رقم معين ايه
نحن كنا نتواجد بالقرب من هذا المكان الذي
تم استهدافه في منطقه بلوك اثنين في مخيم
جباليا الاحتلال قام باستهداف هذا المكان
ودمر عدد من المنازل وايضا الشارع الرئيسي
تم القصف للشارع الرئيسي هناك شهداء من
الماره ممن كانوا يمرون في هذا الشارع
هناك عشرات الشهداء والاصابات ما زالوا
تحت الركام عدد الشهداء كبير لكن حتى
اللحظه لا يوجد حصيله نهائيه بسبب وجود
مواطنين تحت الركام حتى اللحظه لم يتمكن
احد من الوصول اليهم ايضا من ضمن المصابين
الزملاء الصحفيين اسلام بدر ومحمد احمد
اصيبوا خلال مرورهم من هذا الشارع اثناء
هذا القصف ايه ايضا هناك عدد كبير من
الاطفال والنساء ممن اصيبوا وممن استشهدوا
في هذا المكان بعد قصف الاحتلال لمنطقه
بلوك اثنين في مخيم جباليا طبعا حتى
اللحظه محاولات انتشال جثامين الشهداء ومن
هم احياء تحت الركام ما زالت مستمره
بالامكانيات البسيطه الاهالي يحاولون
الوصول للبعض منهم لكن هناك صعوبه في
الامر والاعداد كبيره لا يوجد اي مستشفيات
او اي مراكز صحيه تستقبل هذه الاعداد بعد
ارتكاب الاحتلال هذه المجزره قبل قليل
ا هذا المربع السكني يقع في بلوك اثنين
انس كما ذكرت لنا وهي مواقع استهدفت قبل
اليوم في مخيم جباليا الى اين يذهب سكان
هذه المواقع التي
تستهدف حتى اللحظه لا ماوى لهم السكان
يتنقلون من مكان لاخر الى مراكز اللواء
ومن ثم يحاولون البحث عن مكان امن لكن حتى
اللحظه لا يوجد اي مكان امن حتى المدارس
او مراكز اللواء غير امنه كل يوم الشظايا
وقذائف المدفعيه تتساقط على مراكز اللواء
لا يوجد اي مكان امن للمواطنين لكن
يحاولون البحث عن مكان امن والتنقل من
مكان لاخر لكن اينما يذهبون هناك
استهدافات وهناك غارات جل الشهداء من
الماره في هذا الطريق لان و تم استهداف
ايضا من ضمن الاستهدافات اثناء استهداف
المنازل واستهدف الشارع وهذا شارع رئيسي
هو شارع يعني رئيسي لهذه المنطقه لمنطقه
بلوك اثنين من جنوب نادي خدمات جباليه في
مقيم جباليه يعني معظم الشهداء من الماره
ممن كانوا يعملون على عربات الحيوانات
ايضا هناك شهداء عدد كبير منهم من
المواطنين ام كذلك الطرقات صعبه ووصول
المسعفين وعناصر الدفاع المدني الى
المواقع المست استهدف يكاد يكون مستحيلا
انس في ظل هذه الظروف كيف يتصرف الاهالي
هناك حيال ذلك من يقوم بعمليات الانتشال
والاسعاف هناك صعوبه جدا في التنقل
والتحرك بين المناطق وبين الشوارع بسبب
الدمار المتراكم في الشوارع في كل شارع
هناك منازل مدمره الشوارع مغلقه لا تستطيع
حتى ان توفرت اي مركبات او اي تحركات لا
تستطيع الطواقم تحرك بين الشوارع بسبب
الدمار الذي يغلق هذا الشوارع طبعا طواقم
الدفاع المدني منذ البدايه بسبب الاستهداف
المباشر لها وايضا امس الليله تم استهداف
طواقم الدفاع المدني في مخيم جباليا
بالقرب من مستشفى اليمن السعيد واصيب عدد
من الكوادر فلا يوجد اي امكانيات لمحاوله
انشال التامين او حتى من هم احياء هناك
عدد من المصابين اصاباتهم طفيفه واصابات
متوسطه ممكن انقاذهم لكن بسبب عدم توفر
الامكانيات ينزف لساعات ومن ثم يستشهد في
المكان